this week is food allergy week it's a
time to raise awareness for the more
than 250,000 young people across
Australia who live with some form of
diagnosed food allergy now this is a
really personal thing for me because
three of those 250,000 children are my
kids and having been a parent of
children with allergy for more than 10
years now and there are some things
which I've come to understand which I
didn't appreciate at first having not
really grown up with food allergy myself
and I want to help you understand and
appreciate some of that right now if
it's not is living with food food
allergy is tough but it's not
necessarily tough in the way that you
would expect I think about the fact that
I think most people get alright it would
be logistical difficult in some ways to
make sure that you're always cooking the
right foods that you can't I you know
just go out to a restaurant for instance
and buy anything that you like off the
menu because it may have ingredients
that you or your relatives or friends
cannot eat so I think sort of it's
understandable that there are physical
difficulties with that and that's an
immense challenge but the longer I live
and look after my kids the more I start
to realize actually much more than the
physical challenges of living with food
allergy I think it's the social
challenges that are much more difficult
to work with you see in every society
and culture around the world food meals
you know these are the kinds of things
around which we gather socially if you
want to have a chat with someone you
don't usually just meet up randomly you
say hey let's go grab a coffee or you
know a dinner or a lunch this is a
normal way to bond with your friends or
your colleagues or form a relationship
with someone who you don't know maybe
you want to get a business relationship
with them or become closer friends now
because food is sort of integral to all
of those different kinds of meetings we
sort of forget that when you have
someone with food allergy there are lots
of those kinds of interactions that
become rather than something joyous and
relaxed they become a cause for concern
of course for sort of questioning
yourself and or am I going to be able to
actually meet this person is it going to
be really awkward it becomes a cause of
anxiety rather than
of joy and so I guess what I want to say
to everyone across Australia is that
food allergy is something which has a
deep and profound effect on who you are
the way you were relate to others far
more than you would think we eat so many
times a day and for someone like me I
often don't think that much about what I
myself am eating but for those of food
allergy they don't have that luxury and
it's something which I've started to
appreciate more as a parent so I guess
what I'd love everyone to be conscious
of is that food allergy is something
which really drastically changes your
life and it's much more common than you
realize so spare a thought I think about
those 250,000 young people is actually
more than half a million I put young
people and adults across Australia who
have a diagnosed form of food allergy
and recognize that these are people who
want to be inclusive of our
relationships and family networks just
as much as everyone else and sometimes
it can be really helpful to be aware of
their specific needs people with food
allergies aren't always going to be in a
hurry to point out that they have food
allergies because it can be a cause of
anxiety and many people don't understand
it would be lovely if we didn't have to
think about that if we could actually
say yes I know you're going to
appreciate the challenges that I go
through so please this food allergy week
think about the people around you who
might be in this situation and be
understanding reach out to them and try
to understand what it is that their life
is like as they go through their daily
meals and interacting with people cheers
guys